JENNY BROWN: Welcome back
to "Cloud Storage Bytes."
So far, we've talked
a lot about how
to use Google Cloud
Storage, from managing data
to optimizing performance.
But there is one important topic
that we haven't discussed yet,
the price tag.
Have you ever gone grocery
shopping while you're hungry
and you ended up blowing your
budget right out of the water?
I find that a list can be
really helpful for me here
so that I don't overestimate
my snack requirements.
This kind of planning can be
helpful with cloud storage too.
Just like going
grocery shopping,
it's a good idea to
predict and track
your data usage so you can
anticipate your monthly costs.
Since Cloud Storage Billing is
a little bit more complicated
than grocery shopping, we'll
need to take a closer look.
Pricing is a compilation of
several different components--
data storage, networking,
operations, and retrieval
and early deletion fees.
Each of these components
has its own pricing tables
that show costs based on factors
such as region and operation
type.
This means that each
company's total cost
is going to be
completely different
and based upon
specific requirements.
So as much as I'd like to tell
you exactly what your bottom
line is going to be, I can't.
Instead, I can give an overview
of each pricing category
using my company, Jen's Jams.
Suppose I have the
following storage usage
pattern in a given month.
Let's find out how much
my company will pay.
The first two lines here are
in the data storage category.
Data storage costs apply to your
at-rest storage of your data
in cloud storage.
For a quick refresher,
at rest means
that the data is physically
on the disk itself and not
somewhere else in transit
through the network
or only temporarily
housed there.
Regional or
multi-regional storage
is appropriate for storing data
that's frequently accessed,
such as serving website content,
interactive workloads, or data
supporting mobile and
gaming applications.
For Jen's Jams, we've picked
multi-regional storage
because we've got customers
all over the world.
My company's costs for
multi-region storage
is $0.026 per gigabyte.
So the total cost for
multi-regional storage
this month is going
to be $1,597.44.
The majority of
my company's music
is held in the
multi-regional storage
so that each song can be
as accessible as possible.
The next expense is
also for data storage,
but this is for
nearline storage.
Nearline storage,
as you'd remember,
is a low-cost, highly
durable storage service
for storing infrequently
accessed data.
It's a better choice than
multi-regional storage
or regional storage
in scenarios where
slightly lower availability,
30-day minimum storage
duration, and costs
for data access
are acceptable trade-offs
for lower storage costs.
Nearline storage is ideal for
infrequently read or modified
data.
We're talking once
a month or less.
And nearline storage is also
appropriate for data backup,
disaster recovery,
and archival storage.
At Jen's Jams, we
use nearline storage
to backup our music
collection in the event
that a song gets lost.
I also use nearline
storage for songs that
are rarely ever downloaded.
Nearline storage for the
US multi-region location
is $0.01 per gigabyte.
So the total cost
here is $1,024.
Notice that this is
less than the total cost
of multi-regional storage, even
though I'm storing more data.
Next up in my pricing
table is network costs.
Network usage charges apply
when an object or object
metadata is read from your
buckets, that is, egress.
The cost depends
on several factors
and includes
caveats, for example,
circumstances with the
network egress within GCP.
For example, data
egress from your bucket
to a non-cloud storage
Google Cloud Platform service
is free if your bucket
is located in a region,
the GCP service is
located in a multi-region,
and both locations are
on the same continent.
So accessing data in a US East
1 bucket with a US app engine
instance would be free.
My company's egress falls
under general network usage,
so none of those
special use cases apply.
Network ingress is free.
An operation is an action that
makes changes to or retrieves
information about buckets
and objects in cloud storage.
Operations are divided into
three different categories,
class A, class B, and free.
There's a lot to each of these
categories, so, for details,
go ahead and check the
linked documentation.
Costs for operations
vary by operation class
and storage class.
In my case, class A operations
are in multi-region storage,
so the cost is $0.05
per 10,000 operations.
There are class B operations
in multi-regional storage
data and nearline
storage data, and those
are priced differently.
My totals are $4.00 and
$1.00, respectively.
Because nearline storage
and coldline storage
are intended for storing
infrequently accessed data,
there are additional costs
associated with retrieval
and minimum storage durations.
But again, more about
that in the documentation.
And there you have it.
My company's cloud
storage usage comes out
to a total of $7,460.22.
There's quite a
bit more to billing
than what I've shown you today.
And prices may change after
this video is released.
So please be sure to check
out the documentation linked
below for the most up-to-date
pricing information.
There's plenty more to
discuss about billing,
but that's a totally
different episode.
Don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us on this
quick byte of cloud storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]